as violence in Gaza in Israel continues
another battle is being waged this one
in the media that's because when it
comes to Israel in Palestine the
coverage itself often becomes the story
Jon Stewart summed up how hard it can be
to report the news
we'll start tonight in the Middle East
where Israel what Israel isn't supposed
to defend oh yeah Mexico bomb Texas will
be exiting their country held to the
same standards even so here's some of
the top moments when the media got
people just as heated let's start with
newspapers a Washington Post headline
came under fire for proclaiming two
Israelis killed in Gaza clashes despite
the fact that dozens of Palestinian
civilians were killed in chevalier
Agha's a suburb that same day and the
New York Times was criticized when it
ran the headline missile at beachside
Gaza cafe finds patrons poised for World
Cup they later changed the headline to
reflect the fact that the Israeli
missile in question actually killed at
least eight Palestinians
The Times was also called out from the
other side by the pro-israel watchdog
camera which put up a billboard slamming
the paper for attacking Israel just like
Hamas then there's the journalists on
the ground CNN reporter Diana Magnay
said she was threatened by a group of
Israelis cheering on the bombing of Gaza
and tweeted about it calling them scum
she got pulled off the story after that
and sent to Moscow but criticism of the
whole ordeal flooded social media as did
the outrage that followed NBC News's
decision to pull their correspondent a
man Wahine from Gaza despite his high
profile reporting which won a lot of
praise some speculated that Mohideen who
covered Israel's previous two military
offences in Gaza and actually lived
there for two years was being censored
because his reports had humanized
Palestinian suffering after the uproar
NBC reversed its decision and issued a
statement that left many questions
unanswered and critics unsatisfied but
still his return to Gaza has been hailed
as a victory for fair and truthful
reporting
finally folks in TV studios aren't
immune to controversy either MSNBC
contributor rulership really got a lot
of attention when she protested what she
called the media's pro-israel bias we're
ridiculous
we are disgustingly biased when it comes
to this issue after those comments your
buddy has tweeted that she may have lost
her job and now that's become the story
all of these incidents highlight how
social media is playing a major role not
just in showing what's happening on the
ground but also in holding the
mainstream media accountable NBC
couldn't ignore the thousands of tweets
blasting their move to pull Mohideen
just like ABC couldn't ignore all the
tweets condemning Diane Sawyer for
saying that a bombings aftermath was in
Israel what really it was in Gaza so
what do you think the social media
making the israel-palestine coverage
more accurate give us your take and let
us know how our coverage has been by
tweeting us at aj+
[Music]
you